les soutiens d'al hira des sons venus en
nombre vendredi 15 octobre pour voir la
tête de liste génération être élu maire
lors de ce conseil d'installation mois
avec trente et une voix il ya énormément
de travail à réaliser à trappes on se
bat pour l'égalité pour la dignité des
habitants de cette ville il ya eu
beaucoup d'intelligence dans cette
campagne qui a été violente qui a été
rude où je vous ai pris beaucoup de
coups personnellement mais j'ai surtout
perçu la capacité extraordinaire
d'engagement de mobilisation des
trappistes le travail le travail le
travail cette fois dans la sérénité
l'apaisement loin des polémiques lancées
par nos adversaires du côté de
l'opposition othman nasri et mustapha
larbaoui de la liste union républicaine
pour trappe était absent guy malandain
s'est quant à lui absenté après avoir
refusé de présider la séance et le vote
pour élire les deals luc miserait seul
représentant de trappes à gauche a voté
blanc je serai en soutien de tout ce qui
est positif pour les trappistes et quand
j'aurai une différence est signifiée je
le ferai de manière constructive comme
on l'a fait de 2014 à 2020 avec trappe à
gauche on est très attentif sur sur les
aspects du logement de la vie des
habitants et
il ya des réponses extrêmement
importantes apportées à ce niveau là on
est très vigilant sur l'éducatif c'est à
dire que nous on pense qu'il faut
beaucoup plus de qualité une soirée
tendue à l'image de la campagne le
conseil d'installation a aussi élu aux
adjoints au maire
[Applaudissements]